I really want to start with a sincere
this is one of my favorite films of the
year uh I can't say enough good things
and that's all I have um have a
fantastic day no um I'm curious so You'
obviously never made a film before never
worked on anything like this so what
actually surprised you about making like
a big Hollywood movie I mean every
literally everything was was a surprise
to me I didn't know anything about it
like the fact that you film things out
of order
you know you have marks that you have to
hit on the ground eyelines with the
camera all of that stuff was just crazy
new to me I didn't know I was doing and
I guess all I really had to fall back on
was just you know the acting experience
I had in high school and trying to
translate that into this film experience
what was I want to ask specifically
about the filming out of order what is
it like or was it easy for you to like
um you know get you're filming something
maybe in the third act on day one
beginning a First Act on day two
emotionally trying to figure out where
you are in the story can you sort of
talk about that totally yeah and I mean
that you know every every night before
you go to bed that's kind of the process
that I found myself going through was
just keeping tabs on where we are in the
story and and making sure I can be in
the right head space for for where I
needed to be the next day and maybe for
Paul and divine it was just quicker for
them and easier to to to snap into that
but I really found that I had to take
the time to to make sure I knew where we
were you know every day uh Paul is one
of my favorite actors he's just
phenomenal so I'm imagining that first
day of filming and the first week you
are studying that guy just figuring out
what is he doing how can I mimic this
did you do that and what did you
actually take away from watching him in
the rest of the cast that you sort of
you know brought to yourself and helped
your
performance yeah I think with Paul uh
obviously knowing his work and and
seening and everything he's done in the
past but finally being on set with him
just watching how him and also Divine
the way they take notes uh and the way
they're able to respond to what
Alexander is asking for um and just the
little the little tricks that they use
with with the camera and their awareness
and that those are the things that I was
taking notes on you know I mean
obviously when you're in the scene
focusing you you have to be in it but
that was it was you know film school for
me and an acting school really just
watching them in their scenes and I
could stay back and experience that
so special what day of the shoot did you
maybe get more used to a camera being
right in front of you or was it always
like wait there's a huge camera right
here uh I I don't know if I ever got
like used to it you know but I guess I
felt most comfortable yeah there was 50
days total Maybe by day 48 49 or
something I was feeling a little bit
better about it but no I was I was
always aware of it and you know Alex
Ander thinks I've you know had such an
easy time but no it was definitely some
nerves for sure yeah and specifically
nerves so it's the night before the
first day of filming did you sleep five
minutes or 3
minutes uh maybe four and a half
somewhere yeah but uh no I actually got
good sleep that night I felt a weird
sense of Tranquility going into this
whole process I mean I I I'd met
everybody I had you know met the writer
i' met Alexander I knew you know what
was kind kind of ahead of me at this
point and it was really just about
finally trusting myself you know and I
think in those final weeks where I
finally got cast in the movie I found a
place where I trusted myself and was
able to go in with confidence when you
saw the shooting schedule you must did
you Circle a day on the shoot and say
this is going to be a really effing hard
day or oh my God I can't wait to film
this I think yes the scene with where I
see my dad in the hospital I think is
the one of those scenes that was hard to
prepare for because you know you I had
gotten a chance to meet the actor who
plays my father over Zoom but you know
you have this idea of who this person is
you you're building this backstory who
is my dad what is that relationship like
and then a lot of that kind of gets
thrown out the window when you meet the
person on the day and you're you're
actually seeing them for the first time
and you have to troubleshoot you know
what you've created in your mind and
what they're now bringing to you you
know so was a challenging one but
definitely a rewarding scene for sure
I've spoken to a lot of people uh a lot
of actors and they talk about uh there's
no right way to deliver emot an
emotional scene because everyone is so
unique so I'm just curious when you're
playing an emotional scene are you the
night before thinking about exactly how
you want to play it or do you sort of
find it or did you find it like in the
moment of the scene yeah I think when it
when it comes to to those emotions that
you're trying to elicit naturally you
you really have to rely on what's coming
in that moment you know and and anything
you try to think about or prepare for
it's an audience isn't going to buy that
you know so uh whether or not you cry is
you know not really important just as
long as it's real you know as long as
it's true um and then that's just an
example what people like to use but
that's kind of how I feel about it it's
just going in willing to receive from
your other actors other performers I
know that you've probably talked about
it a lot but getting cast in this must
have been an adventure and I'm just
curious at what point in the casting
process did you actually think wait a
minute I might be getting this I think
um the first time I met Paul over Zoom I
thought uh this might work out because
yeah I didn't I didn't know you know I
had a hard time early on seeing myself
in the role it was originally scripted
for a younger student so I had a hard
time you know a lot of the process I was
trying to play younger and that just
wasn't working and
you know I just didn't really fully see
it until I was able to read with Paul
and and receive from him and and get you
know his perception of of the script and
all of that where I was like yeah I this
makes sense now I can see myself doing
this and I think from that point is yeah
I really just was able to hit the ground
running so I believe you were at
boarding school where you were
discovered um were you because obviously
you have your own personal experiences
at a boarding school uh were you able to
add any of that or did you suggest to
Alexander hey we're missing this you can
we maybe play with this um well nothing
major no but there was little things I
mean uh for example Paul and I in the
script that originally had called the
teachers professors and Paul and I both
of us having been to boarding schools we
were like they're not called professors
they need to be called teachers or
instructors even so it was you know
little things like that that you know
Paul and I definitely had awareness of
and could relate to certain things that
Alexander couldn't I believe you are and
I could be wrong uh studying at Carnegie
melon yeah I'm taking a leave of absence
this year but I was able to do my
freshman year last year and a little bit
of the the fall term this year yeah I
was going to ask um are you this has to
be weird for you like going out and
talking about are you enjoying the
talking about like the movie and sort of
you know what I mean or sort of like a
little weird to sit in a room all day
and just sort of you know what I mean it
is weird yeah I mean especially cuz it
happened year and a half almost two
years ago now so you're you know
remembering all these things and going
back in time a little bit um but yeah
it's it's just exciting generally I
think I'm just grateful for it and I
just have to keep reminding myself of
that is you know whenever I feel like
overwhelmed or like I'm losing my mind a
little bit I just have to be grateful
you know for what's going on you know
totally I will also say like the next
few weeks for you are probably the most
important just because this is when
Hollywood sees the movie and when
casting agents will see it and you know
it's like it's like being in front of
every casting agent without actually
taking a meeting totally yeah and I mean
I you know I'd love to keep doing movies
i' love to keep acting and if I you know
get well received and I get more
opportunities that's that's incredible I
I I love doing this stuff really on that
note um seriously congratulations great
movie good luck with the rest of your
speed dating thank you so
much